Angel Falls I give you
Christmas the lights are so pretty this
is
perfect what did you
eat help me somebody please help me no
please wake
up
Mar
Waters last Christmas still haunts
me it's time to let that go no one
cares everyone would be better off if I
was never
born did you see that did the power go
up oh my
God I stood under the Aurora and said
everyone would be better off if I never
existed
well wish granted Angel strikes every
couple of weeks how can that be do I
know you it's Winnie you know that okay
this hurt hi hi I'm Henry Waters you're
safe now he's not going to get
you no one in this town knows me who are
you dad you weren't around to stop him
so he just kept going he likes
killing I'm here now let's have some
fun hey you hey Merry Christmas
[Music]
we got to stop him and get my life
back you be safe
now
man